yes people can hone their skills and i
think a lot of people should most people
should take especially an actor you
should do that yeah but
groundlings i i think it's important to
yeah to get out of your skin to get it
you know out of your comfort zone and be
able to just commit being the moment yes
be in the moment commit not
you know take that shell and whatever
that is that gloss that whatever that
that it that's impeding you your
progress taking that off and being able
to just to open up and and do things
it's scary it's extremely very scary to
open up and just go whatever comes out
of your mouth and kind of just listen
and try to make something out of nothing
i get nervous every show every show
every show like you feel like i can't do
this
not that i can't do this but
i'm not going to do this well
yeah i'm not going to do this well um
you know
after a while you've built up
a i don't know you built up a superpower
and so
people are coming to see you now
so
this is
might be the last time they ever see you
or you know
live you know have you bombed before
yeah i mean like really just been not
like i'm like oh i'm not
i'm not good tonight i'm
seriously not good yeah no that's never
happened really yeah you've never been
like damn i was off
maybe in a scene but yeah i was yeah in
the scene but then i turned it up you
know
you just i don't know you just curry you
know
you you're confident like yeah okay i
missed that one steph curry but give me
the ball all right
oh i'm gonna hit these threes it's gonna
take a second right you know if i still
remember who i am right i'm still dope
still good still me it's still
cedric you know what would you rather do
if you had a choice i mean scripted
or improvised improvisate
improvisate or script i
i enjoy
scripts i really do i do
i love the written word i do
some people love
you know if they if they didn't have a
script
you know and not
have to memorize you know
for the rest of their life then that
that would be great but not not me i i
like i like scripts i like i love
writers i i've tried to write myself and
you know so i i enjoy that
but
you know i've built up this other thing
and so
i'm able to help writers with
with something
if they need it right
but like larry david and you work with
larry david on curve of your enthusiasm
yes
you supposedly get a piece of paper that
says this is where we want the scene to
go yes go for it yeah go improvise
is that
is that difficult
no or you like that because it's like
okay i know where i'm going it's easier
it's easier definitely easier than what
then on reno when we don't have any kind
of paper
they're just like this is a scene right
here this is
could you just go do it uh there's a
whole new guy yeah uh gary anthony
williams he's gonna be uh masturbating
on an escalator
[Music]
go
you know that's it that's it
and that's is it scary no that's that
now that's fun
doing a live show
scary
but theater but scary scary yeah
somebody gives you this is what the
scene is easy you like it it's on film
were you star struck with working with
larry david
no
not at all no
uh
no
you